you've been locked away for life it  seems like years perfecting this record  it's done now well I still have one more  thing to mix with Maddie I keep adding  songs gonna have a life yeah we go on a  date can we still be in love with you  Mike are you single are you looking are  you single char Lee puth  dishing on his personal life to ET at  Sunday's I Heart Radio Music Awards sure  no I'm saying I'm ready to find my wife  that's what I'm ready to find a  companion man Charlie we're gonna travel  around the world with me give me a big  hug oh I mean I can't because I'm  married but listen we can find you  someone Charlie look at there's tons of  people here today